[Musique]
bienvenue à tous il ya une semaine tout
juste les rivières et les fleuves
sortait de leur cours une partie de la
france avait les pieds dans l'eau
aujourd'hui l'heure est donc à la décrue
mais un département reste au centre des
regards l'essonne la balle au monte
encore les habitants ne sont pas tirés
d'affaires mathieu boisseau eric de la
nuit depuis l'hélicoptère pas de doute
la scène est toujours hors de son lit
ici à morsang sur seine les jardins des
maisons restent inondées et la rue n'est
qu'à quelques mètres en quatre jours il
est tombé l'équivalent de deux mois de
pluie
quelques mètres plus loin on ne
distingue plus grand chose de ce court
de tennis
la scène reste à un niveau très élevé
mais la décrue s'amorce la nouvelle
menace
c'est désormais l'essonne d'habitude un
petit affluent aujourd'hui une rivière
surpuissante trois mètres de crue et un
débit 20 fois supérieur à la normale à
corbeil-essonnes l'eau s'infiltre déjà
près des maisons du travail j'ai eu la
surprise de voir ça on voit plus la
délimitation entre le bras de l'essonne
et le
la parcelle les barrages résiste encore
mais c'est une certitude l'essonne va
continuer de déborder 80000 habitants
sont concernés ceux qui n'ont pas encore
évacué se prépare comme ils le peuvent
on a essayé de protéger en notant des
bastaings de bois du pôle yann des sacs
de sable on s'est dit que ça limiterait
le ruissellement après s'il ya un maître
donnant garage
clairement ça servira pas ce soir le
département de l'essonne restent placés
en vigilance orange
le pic de crue est attendue dans les
prochaines heures
[Musique]